my guest this week is the American
anti-gun violence activist Fred
Guttenberg
Fred's 14 year old daughter Jamie was
killed at her High School alongside 16
others by a teenage gunman
I want to talk to him about how so many
have become desensitized to gun violence
and whether he thinks his great friend
President Joe Biden can really tackle
the issue
[Music]
thank you
Fred thank you so much for for being
with me and talking to all of us today I
really appreciate it thank you for um
having me on I I had to start by making
sure we we heard just something about
your daughter Jamie first of all because
this is this is why we're here and I
wanted to ask if you could be as kind to
tell us a little bit about what she was
like
my daughter
um
was what every parent would hope for in
a child she was kind
she was beautiful
she was decent she was tough
she was well behaved my daughter was a
competitive dancer that's how she spent
her time out of school
constantly practicing to dance but what
she also was
is somebody who
understood that not all kids have the
same abilities and so she dedicated her
personal time when she wasn't in school
when she wasn't dancing to volunteering
for different groups of kids with
differing abilities to make sure they
had all the same types of opportunities
for social connections and for
development
when she was in school she despised
bullies and would put herself in the
middle of somebody bullying and somebody
being bullied to make it stop to the
point whereas her dad I sometimes got
real nervous about it
but that's who she was you know and and
I wasn't gonna stop her from being that
amazing
person
she had her life figured out she knew
what she wanted going forward she wanted
to be a pediatric physical therapist she
dreamed of working in a place called The
Paley Institute where they do surgeries
and kids with limb deformities to help a
child walk for the first time she wanted
to be married by the time she was 25
she had life figured out she was amazing
yeah she she sounds like she had a lot
figured out and a lot of Ambitions and
hopes and
I suppose something that you you have
spoken about and I know would be a
situation any parent would find
themselves in if they were in your
situation which sadly many parents are
in America part of your work is looking
at that yeah
is you will have rerun that day many
times in your mind if you don't mind me
asking this as well I did want to ask
what you remember about that morning she
went off to school
well let's start with the fact that it
was Valentine's Day February 14th and it
was a perfectly normal morning
um and I say normal with all the good
and the bad you know the kids were
getting ready for school and they were
running late and being siblings they
were blaming one another my son was the
driver he was going to drive them both
and because they were running late
I was rushing them out the door
and I kept on telling them you've got to
go you got to go you're gonna be late
you got to get to school and those were
the last words to My Two children that
morning my last words to my son and my
daughter that morning were not I love
you it was you gotta go you're gonna be
late
I was sending them to school I never
expected that later that day I would
find out I would never get the chance
again to tell my daughter how much I
love her
but I didn't do it that morning
and it is something I will live with for
the rest of my life it is the reason why
I tell every parent and everybody who
loves somebody else to make sure you
never miss the chance to look someone in
the eye
and tell them eyeball to eyeball how
much you love them
because you never know when you won't
get that chance again
it's such an important message thank you
for for sharing that Fred
I really appreciate it and thank you you
are then in your day it's February 14th
and going about your business as usual
yeah and and how do you learn something
is wrong is there a phone call how does
this knowledge start to reach you
just after 2 p.m I get a phone call from
my son and you know kids in school today
have cell phones so there's regular
communication throughout the day uh and
my son calls me just after two and he
was a bit of a jokester
so he calls and he says dad there's a
shooting at my school
my initial Instinct was what the heck is
he talking about you know that's a weird
thing to make a joke about but what is
he talking about
but he immediately then said and I can't
find Jamie now my son looked after his
sister like a hawk he would never play
games with her safety and the second he
said that I knew this wasn't a joke and
he was serious
and so I said where are you and he said
they're making us all run but I can't
find Jamie and I said you need to run he
goes but I can't find Jamie it's he kept
saying it to me over and over and
telling me he wants to turn around and
go to where they know the shooting was
happening which that building and I'm
like you can't do that you need to run
I'll worry about your sister
and as I'm on the phone with him and
he's crying to me that he can't find his
sister
there's there's gunshots
as I'm on the phone with him it's the
shots on the third floor it's the shots
that were killing his sister
he listened to them and I listened to
them on the phone while I was speaking
to him convincing him to run
because of those shots
I was able to finally convince him to
keep just running as far from that noise
as he could and he made it to safety
um unfortunately the rest of that
afternoon was all about my wife and I
trying to find our daughter
hoping she was okay hoping the fact that
we couldn't reach her was only because
maybe she dropped her phone and
eventually she calls from somebody
else's phone it was getting to the
hospital so that we could
try to find her there hoping she was now
injured and couldn't reach us
um
and it wasn't until you know around 5
30ish when we learned through a friend
of mine who was a police officer that
she was shot and killed
I'm so sorry
thank you
I really am and
apart from all the the things that will
come with such devastation
your life really changed that day in a
con completely other way because of how
we're speaking now which is which is
part of your message you you suddenly
found yourself in a position where you
knew about the violence the gun violence
the mass shootings in America but you
obviously until that point hadn't known
about them in quite the same way
and and you find yourself with a Cause
listen I I live with this intense guilt
that my voice wasn't a part of this
before it was my family
uh I'll never get over that
but it's a part of this
um cause now
the crazy thing is it didn't happen
immediately the first 24 hours are were
actually a blur it while I knew my
daughter was killed I hadn't really
started to focus on the notion that this
was gun violence until the next day at
night when I went to the Parkland vigil
um and at that vigil the mayor asked if
I wanted to take her speaking slot
and I hadn't prepared anything but I
said you know what the heck
um and I went up there and I looked at
this crowd of people thousands of people
crying with candles and lights
and that was the moment where it hit me
that this was gun violence that that
broke my family that broke my community
and I I just remember telling people
that vigil about my daughter
but saying to everyone in the crowd this
time gun violence
came to the wrong family to the wrong
dad and to the wrong community and I
went home that night and I walked in my
house and I said to my family and
friends who were there who didn't go to
the vigil I'm going to break that effing
gun lobby and it's been my mission ever
since is to break that Lobby and to
break their grip on our legislators and
making and getting effective legislation
to do something about gun violence in
America and uh
I can't stop
well there are many people who are very
grateful to you because they would also
say that they would be scared to do it
you know because of the carrying of guns
and because of the threats because of
the risk sure are you ever scared to to
speak up and and say anything because of
what's happened to your family as well
yeah
well because of what happened to my
family
I've lost this capacity for fear
um what my daughter had running down the
hallway with an active shooter carrying
an AR-15 at her back you know people
need to remember my daughter knew it
wasn't like she was caught by surprise
she knew what she was running from she
was in the hallway she was the second to
last to be shot she made it to within
one second of safety
um
what she had was fear
genuine real fear that I'll never ever
fully be able to understand
or comprehend and because I'll never
have the level of fear that she had
you can't intimidate me anymore
you you can't words won't do it
what I really have found more than that
is the majority of people in this
country
have been supportive
have been amazing and give me hope
because the majority of people in this
country are like me
it's not that they're anti-gun it's
their anti-gun violence they want to do
something about that and so for every
person who tries to intimidate or
threaten I can genuinely say I don't
care but to everybody
who understands what my mission is and
is supportive
I can genuinely say thank you and I hear
you because I do and yet
what you said and I'm very struck by I'm
moved by it where you said at the
beginning of our conversation that you
have guilt about not
adding your voice before
doesn't mean you didn't care it's about
something else which I wanted to get
your view on which is
how do you get people to care to the
point where they also push for change or
rather how do you stop people from being
desensitized to this because it's so
common gun violence in America how do
you do that
you know it's such a great question and
and I look back
and I'll just use Sandy Hook as an
example
I felt horrible emotion over it anger
over it I watched all the news reporting
over it and I did nothing
I did nothing
um
and I and I lived in this bubble I mean
this was Parkland Florida this was the
community actually a lot like Newtown
where you never see this happening
um and
I allowed myself to stay in this bubble
part of what I do now to help people
care
people always say to me I can't imagine
how you feel
I go out of my way every chance I get
to help people imagine how I feel
to help people imagine the terror to
help people imagine the violence and to
help people imagine themselves in that
and not me because I think at the end of
the day
the more people realize while this
happened to somebody else
but it could happen to me when I go to
the mall it could happen to me when I go
to the shopping center or the movie it
could happen to my family when I send
them to school
the more likely they are to become part
of solving it and I will tell you if you
look at the last three elections in this
country
doing something about gun violence has
been a top voting issue it has changed
election outcomes and I think people are
listening now and I if you if you look
at polls
over 80 percent of America wants to
solve this we are winning the fight
but moving the political system in this
country is a lot of work well I mean you
say that as well but I'm also aware that
we've seen recently in states where
there have been mass shootings
politicians re-elected who are anti-gun
reform as well I mean there is that
reality they may have been voted for for
other policies politics is not a one
policy thing of course but you've spoken
very publicly about your bond with the
president with Joe Biden yeah I know
that he was an important figure for you
and a relationship you say you wouldn't
have without what happened to you and
your family but do you have faith that
he can be the president to make that
change because you know there isn't that
much longer left in some ways and we
don't know what's going to happen next
without question not only do I have
faith
I can actually point to the fact that
something has already been accomplished
that is historic and hasn't happened in
over 30 years which was back in April he
signed the safer communities act a real
piece of gun violence prevention
legislation that does really big things
to start to finally bend the curve and
reduce gun violence is it everything I
could have hoped for is it everything I
would have wanted well no it's not it's
but it was a real significant package
that was able to get bipartisan support
and I'm actually
um to this day so thankful for his
leadership on that for the leadership of
people like my friend Senator Chris
Murphy who negotiated in the Senate
Non-Stop
to get it done even when and he will
tell you this I didn't have faith that
he could get it done I never saw him
being able to accomplish in the Senate
what he did but he got it done but Fred
there's been more violence since there's
been more shootings how do we move or
how do you and the people you're working
with move to to stop that what needs to
change well listen
um and it's a great question if you know
we passed this back in April
if you look back to when my daughter was
killed in 2018 there were about 300
million weapons in America by the time
we passed this legislation
there were 400 million weapons and ghost
guns so the reality is we haven't
you know where the legislation passed
is going to be forward-looking and I
believe will have a real dramatic impact
but we have to come to grips with the
reality of the numbers of weapons that
we have I I will tell you for me
personally the Holy Grail of solving gun
violence in America at this point
because of the numbers of guns that are
out there is through ammunition
um and I am working to pass something in
the United States Congress called
Jamie's law which seeks to extend
background checks to ammunition there's
no requirement for a background check on
ammunition so you have all these weapons
out there many of which are in the hands
of people who are what's called a
prohibited purchaser so they have to get
their gun illegally or they steal it or
they trade for it and they walk right
into the storm by the bullets
if we can get background checks on
ammunition we stop that we'll save lives
immediately and so for me that's the
Holy Grail right now of solving this
problem and I'm not going to stop that's
fascinating I I it makes a lot of sense
because of what's already in play like
you talk about and you know we will see
what happens because it's it's so
political and it's such a strong Lobby
this is a kind of a a very simplistic
way of asking something quite complex
but because you've looked at this so
much who do you blame for your
daughter's killing hmm
a lot of people
um let's start
with all of those
who failed to stop it
when they had different chances to do so
let's start with the person who made the
decision to do it
but also
I can't
not
um focus and on the political reality
that we live in a country where that
killer
in spite of all the red flags was able
to buy the gun and so I do blame the
legislators who failed to do anything
meaningful for all of the years I look
at just my daughter was born in 2003.
the year she was born there was actually
a ban on assault weapons in America that
expired in 2004.
and you can look at the trajectory of
sales after that ban expired
you then fast forward to 2007 and the
Heller Supreme Court decision
which
put in place this whole
um phrasing around common use
and the industry
built common use into a business model
and they kept on manufacturing and
flooding our streets with more and more
and more of these weapons every year to
the point where they were no longer just
being used from a hunting or sport
perspective
they were now being used overwhelmingly
in Daily violent
incidents so I blame everybody
who's a part of building that system
whether it's the Supreme Court decision
whether it's all the legislators who
fail to do anything to prevent this
explosion of weapons on our streets
I blame them all
and those legislators who still exist
who refuse to acknowledge the
significance of this problem and who
fight back and who use BS
you know lies to continue to push that
system
they have blood on their hands right now
I blame them right now
and so
stopping the next one
requires defeating still more people
and we're going to continue working to
do it
you mentioned right at the top of that
list
unsurprisingly rightly the Killer
who hasn't been given the death sentence
instead it's it's life in jail
what was your reaction to that quite
recent decision
so the past almost five years now
um
I I've my life has really been very much
um wrapped around what's going to happen
to him
and the trial and that outcome and
because there was going to be this trial
I wanted him to get the ultimate
punishment I wanted him to get the death
sentence
um
and when the verdict was delivered
um for a couple of days I was actually
very distraught
but then I went to visit my daughter at
the cemetery
and I always come back from a visit with
her maybe feeling smarter because in her
own way she communicates with me
and I I left the cemetery and I realized
no matter what happened to the Killer
every day going forward I'm still going
to be visiting my daughter at the
cemetery nothing changed
nothing changes
and it put me in a place where I was
finally able to put the killer out of my
head
he got the punishment he got he's going
to one of the most miserable places on
Earth in the Florida Department of
Corrections
he will face ultimate judgment there I'm
sure
but I'll still be visiting my daughter
at the cemetery
and because of that
it was in that moment where I was
finally able to put that killer out of
my head he's no longer in my head I no
longer think about him
I no longer wonder what's going to
happen to him I no longer have any
um second or minute of of my time
focused on him I'm no longer losing
sleep over him and so while I was
disappointed in the verdict
I'm actually now in a healthier place
than I've been for almost five years
well that's very good to hear and
important as well because the only thing
we can control are our reactions
yeah I'm also just aware of picking up
what we were talking a little bit about
before
that we still amazingly and I say that
in the true sense of the word I have
people who who write horrific things
about these mass shootings who don't
believe them conspiracy theorists
um you'll be very familiar with this
terrain sadly
what do you think of Alex Jones
um I think Alex Jones is the lowest form
of humanity that exists I wish him
nothing but terrible outcomes because of
what he did to other people and
continues to do you know in spite of
these horrible Financial legal judgments
against him
he hasn't stopped Behaving Badly
he is a liar he is somebody who has
directed violence at others he has used
his platform not for good but for evil
and so in his remaining days on Earth I
hope he pays a horrible price
directed by the courts and pursued by
those families that he spent all those
years harassing
and I am certain that when his time is
up
um he will pay a final judgment as well
um he he is he is as low a form of human
life as can exist
you talk about use of platform I also
noticed that when the new owner of
Twitter the other day Elon Musk posted a
photo
uh recently of
a bedside table cans of Diet Coke also a
gun actually transpired to be a toy gun
which I didn't realize at the time sure
uh you chose to post it actually doesn't
matter whether it was real or not
because the message he was trying to
deliver
is what matters yeah I mean I just meant
I didn't know you know but it was a very
striking image you you posted
in response to that uh talking about the
fact that your daughter was killed
everyday children are killed because of
irresponsible adults
what are you what do you feel about that
having also reflected on it
but
so strange
um now watching what Elon Musk is
turning himself into he is a business
person who I was mesmerized by for so
many years who I thought did the coolest
things
um and if he had a vision I
automatically
um thought if Elon Musk thinks he can
pull it off I'll bet you he can I looked
at him that way until his pursuit of
Twitter and what he's turned it into
which is accessible of of indecency in
the worst of humanity and that photo
that he posted is just an example
he was
for whatever reason he felt important to
post this image of Guns by the side of
his bed I spend my life every day
trying to talk about responsible gun
ownership and locking weapons up
two of my dear friends uh people I wish
I didn't know but I do because of gun
violence Mike and Kristen song their son
Ethan was killed because of an unlocked
weapon
and so I don't care that that wasn't a
real weapon because he didn't say that
in his message he implied he's keeping
these unlocked weapons by the side of
his bed and I find that dangerous and I
find that encouraging to others to do
dumb stupid irresponsible things
why he's pursuing this path in his life
now
why he's behaving like the richest troll
in on Earth instead of this successful
business person that he had previously
been I can't make sense of
but I hope he fails we'll see how that
transpires in terms of that platform and
and the owner ownership of that business
and and perhaps also what changes are or
are not made just finally
what do you think Jamie would make of
what you're doing and you'll fight and
how you're going about it
um you know it's funny my my wife and I
have had numerous conversations about
that
um
on one hand
she would be completely embarrassed
by the attention because while my
daughter uh
was always out there performing she was
still a shy little kid and she would be
completely embarrassed by the attention
on the other hand in my home my wife and
my son are very different than me they
were never
um as as into the news and and politics
the way I was but Jamie was Jamie was
the one who would sit with me and watch
and when I would get angry at things
that were happening or uplifted by
things that were happening she was with
me she was participating and so
Jamie because of that and because of her
toughness because of her
dislike of bullies
because of her concern for others
she would be on the one hand embarrassed
but on the other hand I know she would
have her hands on my back saying go Dad
do this
let's save the next one
sounds like my kind of girl getting very
into it her news her politics and and
trying to you know stand up I suppose
for what she believes thank you so much
for telling us about her and also your
your work today I really appreciate the
time and and the insights thank you
and thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again do take care and
goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]